okay I want to tell you right off the
bat if you have any negative comments
about my handwriting I don't want to
hear it okay I've been hearing these
negative comments about my handwriting
for quite some time now I don't need to
your more comments about it anyways
let's get right in so I'm gonna talk
about the power of letters today you
know for me letters mean a lot social
medias change a lot of different things
we communicate through Facebook Twitter
text email many different ways and by
the way I am NOT saying anything they
get about social media I'm a big social
media active advocate myself but there
is something special when I get a
handwritten note from somebody it has so
much meaning to me and I'll tell you why
when I joined the military I'll never
forget when I joined the army April of
1997 I'm in the army we go to the
barracks were by ourselves you're trying
to make friends I'm the only middle
eastern guard or unit two to eight South
Carolina everybody's looking at me funny
and and I'm trying to find and make
friends there but there was a time at
the end of the night that we always sit
together 60 of us from our unit we would
sit there and a mailman would show up
and he would read the last things of
people and it would go alphabetical
order you know they would go Alan
such-and-such such-and-such and the
moment they skip past your last name
your heart was broken because you don't
have anybody to talk to you don't have a
phone you don't have TV don't have
access to nothing to speak to nobody but
if you did get a letter if I did get a
letter folks we read that letter over
and over and over and over and over
again we would run and that would be in
your pocket you'd be having a hard day
the drill sergeant really give you a
hard time your shoulders you can't
PicMonkey reading your book you're
reading your letter and I started
keeping every single one of the letters
I got from the Army when I was in the
army every single one of my life till
today everybody who's ever written a
letter to me from April of 1997 till
today I have the letter anybody that's
ever written a letter to me from April
of 1997 till today I have the letter a
matter of fact you know this is one of
the boxes I have here I have a bunch of
letters in here that I keep and this is
just from the last few years and I was
going through them we found some letter
here from a buddy of mine Mario who in
here he looks like a little
and he knows who he is I love him dearly
I love when I get letters from this dude
and this is an old one do you recognize
this one some of you may recognize this
one this is a from a long time ago and
these are just some of the ones that
I've kept from the years now I also kept
letters for my credit or friends that I
got from ten eleven years ago but these
don't make it in this box because here
you mean something to me here you really
don't mean a lot to me in creditors at
that time really didn't have a lot of
meaning in my life 10 11 years ago but
what I want to encourage you to do
here's what I want to challenge you to
do you got a lot of things going on I
know you do you got a million on one
things going on everybody's busy we all
have a busy a lot everybody today is
very busy half the time we're busy on
our fourth but I understand you're very
busy I want to encourage your challenge
you take a quick timeout take five cards
out take five sheets of paper out write
a letter to five people
surprise them handwritten not a text not
email not Facebook not Twitter send five
letters today right now not two hours
from now write it right now stop just do
nothing
write five letters right now and mail
them out and look what happens there is
something special
anybody who gets a handwritten note from
anybody especially nowadays more than
ever before I want to encourage you and
challenge you to do that and see what
happens with the magic of your writing
letters to other people and how the law
of reciprocity starts working back for
you as well it's my message of the week
um please be sure to share the video as
well as subscribe to the channel
you